- Let's be like, I'll write bars.
That's it, that's all I
want to do is write bars.
I would've been like, what?
Man, (bleep) this rap (bleep) man, 29?
Old ass man, aw, hell no man.
I would be proud of myself,
if I produce this whole album
and people be like, "Yo,
who produced that beat?"
Like yeah, you got to
grind, you got to work
for something.
Just hate the whole idea
of, I'm better than you.
We're all the same.
Every artist from 2pac, Eminem, Jay-Z--
- Everybody.
- Fans that did it.
Yeah, I'd do whatever the hell I want,
and if I don't do it, it's
because I didn't want to do it.
They might laugh at me or think I'm weird,
and it's like (bleep) that.
This is what makes you, you.
I wear white contacts and all this stuff
and it looks ridiculous,
but it's still my image.
You never go full retarded.
(whoosh)
- He's an American
rapper, record producer,
director, and actor from
Los Angeles, California.
- He was signed with Ruthless records
and has since founded
his own record label,
Funk Volume.
- He's also known for
his use of white-colored
eye contacts and music
videos, performances,
and interviews.
- He's Hopsin, and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(whoosh)
- You got to be more than
one thing these days.
If you're a rapper,
try to learn to produce
or try to learn to manage yourself
or try to learn how to do
social networking online.
Try to learn how to
book shows for yourself.
Learn something, don't just be like,
"I write bars.
"That's it, that's all I
want to do is write bars.
"Nothing else, nigga."
'Cause then it's like,
oh well you're not really
going to go anywhere because
you're not going to find
a manager who's going to
want to deal with you if
that's really all you do.
It's just going to be
difficult to get anywhere.
When you're trying to reach success
you can't think of the, the long-term.
You just got to go day to day
and enjoy it for the
moments and don't look at
the next man and compare
your story to his going,
"Dang, he did it in
this," or "He got that,
and I'm still over here."
Like you just got to do it day-to-day.
If you've got two fans,
really work that system
with those two fans,
and,
- Turn it to four.
- Yeah, make it four, then eight,
and then just keep it going
and then over the course of a few years,
you've just got thousands
and millions of fans,
and yeah, you just got
to enjoy it day-to-day
and just put that work in.
'Cause if you had told me when I was--
I wanted it at 17 or 18 years old.
That's when I really wanted to be on
and be where I'm at right now.
I wouldn't have been able
to handle it back then
but, if you had told me,
"Man, you ain't going to be
"poppin', you ain't going to be on Hot 97
"'til you 29, nigga."
I would have been like, "What!
"Man, (bleep) this rap (bleep) man, 29!
"Old ass man, oh hell no, man."
I would've did something else.
- Yeah.
- But when I look back at it,
I went through so much
training of learning
how to rap and,
I had my own little
dreams at the time like,
"Okay, it's 2000, it's
2005, I'm 'about to do this,
"I'm 'about to be poppin' on Myspace,
I'ma do this thing."
It didn't happen, but you just keep going
and you fell a lot of times
but eventually you just,
you understand.
- And you learn from
your mistakes.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Of course.
- Yeah, so.
(chuckles)
Yeah, you just got to
put that work in, man.
- Good for you, man.
- Got the day-to-day.
Last year, I was going to retire
before I had announced it,
but then I decided to do
the new album Pound Syndrome
and I pulled the whole retirement stunt.
But the reason I wanted to do
Pound Syndrome was because,
I wanted to ...
I want to make, a self-prod--
I've always produced all my albums,
But I just want to make
a self-produced album
to where the production
just keeps getting doper
and doper and I want to
make that album that just
does something crazy to the industry,
just like, "Yo, he dropped that (bleep)"
but I want to produce it myself.
So I can't, people are always like,
"Why don't you get up
and produce this man?
"You could be big."
It's because I won't be
satisfied if I have a song
on the radio that's really (bleep) huge
if I didn't make it.
Only because I've been producing since
I started rapping, so.
And I'm learning things all the time
just about quality and all that
and the art of mixing
songs and all that, so.
And these are things I
didn't know on my past album,
so there's flaws in my production.
But this album I stepped
it up a little bit more,
so I'm hoping that people can notice that
and if not, I'ma keep on doing it
but I will not stop until I produce
a whole entire project myself,
because that will make me happy,
if I'm going, "I did all that (bleep)
"in my bedroom, dawg and
that (bleep) just (bleep)
"blew the (bleep) up and I
did everything in my bedroom."
That's what makes me happy.
So some people just want to be famous.
The famous thing, that's
not really going to make me,
I'm not going to be proud of myself.
- Yeah.
- I will be proud of myself,
if I produce a whole
album and people be like,
"Yo, who produced that beat?
"Who did-- nigga the production on that,
"that album was fire. Who did you--"
And I just want to be like, "It's just me.
"I just go in a room and just do it
"and just come out with it."
So that's going to satisfy
me, so that's why I decided
to go another round and
put this new album out.
I believe in like,
like on Funk Volume if we
start working with an artist,
they do have to be grinding somewhat just,
but they don't necessarily
have to have a million fans
on Facebook and all that.
It's just that we got
to be able to see that
they have been working.
So there's a guy who's
just dope at rapping,
and he's never been in the studio
and he just has stuff on paper,
and he might have the sickest punchlines
but it's going to be
like, you don't have any
studio experience,
and I don't know how you're going to be.
If you're willing to
promote yourself online
and be on Twitter, be on
Instagram, be on Facebook
chatting with fans.
And this is the bare minimum,
everybody should have
the internet by now.
I know, I mean ... like yeah.
You got to grind, you got
to work for something.
You got to, everybody should have at least
a little cheap ass microphone
that they're recording with,
because I've been doing it in this room
since I was 14 years
old, making little ...
Trying to make it work.
I would build a computer if I had to.
I used to build computers as well.
Build a computer, get a
$8 microphone at Walmart,
download a program, whatever.
You'll find a way if you
really, really want it,
if you're hungry.
So we sign people who,
where you can see that
they've been working.
So if they have a couple videos out.
If you see that their Twitter's
always active and this,
okay, at least they're working so,
we can go in and enhance that now.
But we won't work with somebody
who doesn't do anything
and they're just flat-out dope
and not doing anything 'cause it's like,
You might hold us back.
'Cause that means we have to do more work
and we already do a lot.
So we look for artists
who are already grinding.
Everybody does something great.
It may not be music, but I
don't know why it's like,
society just goes,
"They're celebrities.
"Let's love them more
than we love ourselves
"and praise them and give
them all our attention
"and get nervous when we get around them."
Like nah, dude.
'Cause I'm real with you.
I can meet an artist I've never met.
If you pulled out a pencil
and started drawing,
and you were really good,
I'd be like damn.
I'd be jockin' you like,
"Oh, damn dude that's dope.
"How long you been doin' it?"
'Cause I find it impressive.
I'm not just one to
praise a celebrity like,
"Oh my God you were in a movie?
"Hi, Tom Cruise, wow, you're--"
and then just ignore somebody
else who did something great
who's not a celebrity.
I show love to anybody
who does something great.
Just hate the whole idea
of "I'm better than you."
We're all the same.
Just (bleep) doin' (bleep), you know
at the end of the day it's just a job
and I go home, take a (bleep),
look in the refrigerator,
see what is there to eat and just sit
and watch Family Guy and go
on Netflix and fall asleep.
I don't like making myself seem high like,
Lamborghinis, hot (bleep), swimming pools
in the backyard, barbecues all day.
That's not my life at all.
A lot of people sleep on that.
They don't understand how
big the internet actually is
and how much it can
change somebody's life.
It changed my whole
entire life completely.
If the internet didn't come around,
I'd still be at Interscope
trying to shout my demo like,
"Man, please."
- Standin' out front.
- Yeah, yeah exactly,
and I used to do that.
But it's changed so much,
but I still see artists like,
"Hey man, take my demo."
Dude, or they're like,
"Let me rap for you."
and it's like, that's not going to--
Okay, everybody can rap,
everybody has a dope 16
that they can spit now,
but it's more than that now.
What is your social media game?
How much are you
wanting--
- How many people
believe in you?
- How are you running?
Yeah.
And what artists don't understand
and what kind of upsets me is ...
At the end, they want co-signs
and approvals by people with,
and I had to understand that that didn't,
that didn't have to be the way.
So like I said, I would have
loved to get a major deal
back in the day, but I start to understand
at the end of the day,
the whole music industry,
everything is about the fans.
They are the ones that
keep you guys alive,
they're the ones that keep my label alive.
Every artist from 2pac, Eminem, Jay-Z.
- Everybody.
- Fans that did it.
So ...
These big guys, P-Diddy and whatever,
it's fans that made these people.
It's not these,
these guys--
- And it's even
the corporations.
When you look at any
Fortune 500 big company,
it's consumer behavior and consumer,
your hard-earned money,
- Yeah, exactly.
- that went into making these ...
Things as big as they are.
- Exactly, so,
and I start to understand like,
if you can have a direct
connection with the fans,
then why do I need this guy
to co-sign me or to be next to this guy
when the fans already (bleep) with me?
I just had my whole plan laid out and,
yeah, I'd do whatever the hell I want
And if I don't do it, it's
'cause I didn't want to do it.
These labels don't impress me,
I am the label now.
I am the label and I'm,
whatever, my Facebook, everything I run,
I just do whatever I want and I still get
the same amount of exposure as these,
even sometimes more exposure than a lot of
these people in these big labels,
where they put stuff out
and the label doesn't know
how to promote it or build a buzz
and I'm just over here,
sitting right here,
drinking this goddamn cranberry juice,
posting (bleep) on (bleep) Facebook
and this (bleep) gets a million views fast
and they're just like, "How
do you do that (bleep)?
"Wow, how does he do--"
It's 'cause I built the
(bleep) organically,
I learned how to rap, I talk to my fans,
I'm a humble dude.
Yeah, just building
everything from the ground up,
not sugar-coating anything,
I'm not being fake about anything.
I'm not putting on a fake image.
I'm not having other stars co-sign me
or being next to people
just so I can look cooler
and making people think that I'm doper
than I am, it's just.
It's the realness, I'm just Hopsin,
the guy who knows how to rap and ...
I be online promoting myself
and I started this career and
I got my little team with Funk Volume
and we're all doin' it.
Everybody is the same, man.
I run into these people,
I feel like we ...
Nobody's a real, real individual, like,
it's rare that you stumble across someone
who's a real individual and
when you do it's amazing,
and I love seeing people who
are just truly themselves.
But everybody is like,
whatever they see on TV,
whatever they around them
they just want to be that and it's like
the world is huge, you
don't have to be that.
You do not have to be
what your neighbor is;
you don't have to do what
your neighbor is doing,
you can do whatever the (bleep) you want.
So, people are just,
yeah rappers feel like they
have to be a certain way.
Actors feel like they
People in certain neighborhoods feel like
they have to be a certain way
'cause of who they're around.
I know deep down ...
Like children, children are themselves.
They react off of
instinct until they start
to understand how the world is.
And adults, once they turn into an adult,
they start to see like, "Oh dang,
"I can't do that, I
can't like that no more.
"I can't be that way 'cause
that's not acceptable
"'cause I might get looked down upon,
"they might laugh at
me or think I'm weird."
And it's like nah, (bleep) that,
this is what makes you you.
This is what makes you you.
It's hard to do, don't get me wrong
I'm still learning about myself.
I'm trying to just,
open myself up to new ways
of thinking all the time
and just truly being myself.
But sometimes I get caught in,
there's so many different
levels to a matrix,
you know what I'm sayin'?
Sometimes you're like,
damn, I thought I was out
and I was still in.
- Right, right.
- Like it's just, but.
- That's real.
- But yeah, it's just,
everybody just feels like they have to
be just like everybody
else and when I see rappers
I'm like come on, dude.
You, you--
- They got the same dance.
- Same dance, dude.
- The same turn-up.
- And it's like dude,
you got a billion tattoos
on your face and body,
where did you get that from?
'Cause I know you didn't
come out of your mom's
(bleep) vagina going,
"I want to be tatted."
You saw somebody do that, and you said,
"I want to do that too 'cause
that's going to make me
"look like this type of thing,
"and I want to be just like that.
"And everybody's doing
it, I know that works.
"So I'm going to do it, and
now it makes you look like
"one of them and now you're not original
"and then when your rap
career doesn't go far
"you're like, (bleep). What happened?"
But it's not just rapping,
it's just all areas of life.
- What is the thing that Hopsin learned
that's set him apart from the next dude
who could rap just as well as Hopsin?
- Well.
I say, you can't, you can't be afraid
to make a fool of
yourself, 'cause I'm not.
You got to analyze everything, so.
I study every artist that's poppin'.
Even the ones, even
ones who aren't poppin'.
You got to study everything,
so don't just hate it.
If there's an artist you hate,
and who's not poppin',
just study every detail.
Why is he not poppin'?
Why did this not work for him?
Look at the artist where
something is working.
I don't like a lot of swaggy-type rap,
but I still see things
like when it's poppin'
on the internet and people
are really (bleep) with it,
I try to understand why, like what is it?
I look at all these major
details, even when it comes
to videos, like the
colors that they use, like
man, this is a video,
it's not really my style,
but I can see what it's doing to my brain
when I'm watching it to
make me interested in this.
So I'm like okay, maybe
I need to apply colors
to certain videos, my videos
or do something that way.
Even when it comes to
images of important things,
it's not just bars.
You have to understand
that it's not just bars.
I sound like a freakin'
weird mad scientist
right now 'cause I'm trying to,
put it into words.
- No, you're making perfect
sense.
- Yeah it's not,
when you just have bars,
that's not enough to do it.
It's image, and I have an image,
I wear white contacts and all this stuff
and it looks ridiculous
but it's still my image,
I still have.
I didn't start out doing it this way.
I had to realize okay, this is the route
that I want to take.
It's crazy and weird but I did my homework
and this is going to work for me.
And every artist has
their own thing, you know.
Sure DMX, when he was like,
"I'm going to start barkin', uh."
Like he didn't start,
- That's his signature.
- he had to come up with that.
He had to realize that's what I feel,
this is what I do,
like Eminem with his blonde hair.
It comes to a point
where you got to realize
image plays a part.
50 Cent with the whole
bulletproof vest thing
when he first came out.
You have to have an image.
You can't just be ...
You can be a normal guy
but you have to realize,
"Okay, my image is going
to be a normal guy.
Like that is who I'm going
to present myself as."
When you're just a normal guy
and you're unaware that
you're a normal guy
and you're just wearing a
regular t-shirt and whatever
and you just like, "I got bars, son."
And that's all you got?
It's not enough, you
have to analyze yourself.
What do you look like?
How are you coming off?
It's not just about bars.
It should be in a perfect world,
where we would just listen to your lyrics
but that's not what it is.
Every step I take in life, I
always think about tomorrow.
So I'm like, how is this
going to (bleep) tomorrow?
Is this going to um,
is this going to (bleep)
up tomorrow for me,
or is this just going to be something
that I'm going to do right now,
and I'm able to drop it
tomorrow and not even,
it won't even affect tomorrow?
Some people don't give
a (bleep), they're like,
"Ooh, I'm about to go do this and that."
Then tomorrow comes around,
and by tomorrow it could be
a week later, a year later.
It's just that one day,
night you decided to do
something, it just (bleep) now,
it's impacted your whole life to where
everyday you wake up, it's there now.
Whatever you did.
Could be herpes, could be a kid,
could be you're in prison,
could be something.
It's just like, I don't move like that.
I move where it's like,
let me take this next step.
Is this step going to
(bleep) up tomorrow for me?
If it is, I'm not going to take it.
And there's some steps where it's like,
"I know this is kind of a bad step,
"it's a little on the dark side but,
"it's not going to (bleep)
up tomorrow so I'll do it.
"I'll do this it's not,
let me go yellow for it
"for the night and it
won't (bleep) up tomorrow
"for me and I'll be cool."
You never go full retarded.
It's true, you never go full retarded.
Do not (bleep) up tomorrow,
because tomorrow is what,
tomorrow is what your life depends on.
You may not be depending on it,
but the you in the future's like,
please man, don't (bleep) it up man,
it's all on you man, and
then the you now sometimes
is like, "I don't give a
(bleep) nigga, I'm turnin' up,"
and then it's like, damn.
Now you're 30, 40 years old, uh ...
I shouldn't have did that (bleep).
That's why I like rappers like Macklemore,
he makes you think.
He makes you not want to be stupid.
When you listen to the
music, you actually want to
be better, you don't want to go out
and just be like, "I'ma
go do this (bleep),
I'ma go be a (bleep)," you don't do that.
I'm not trying to be
all extremely positive.
It excites humans to be bad sometimes.
Some people want to go and
have a one-night stand.
Some people want to go get drunk,
some people want to go smoke.
I understand that.
I have my little bad things
that I want to do too,
but never go full retarded.
That's just the way it comes down to.
Don't let your (bleep) up stuff today,
or the little darkness
that you do in today,
cross over into tomorrow,
because that's when it's like yo,
you (bleep) up now.
That (bleep) you did last night,
these mother(bleep)
knockin' at my door now,
they're trying to kill me
or they're trying to do this (bleep)
or they're, whatever.
Don't let it cross over into the next day.
Just leave it at that, leave it there
and just be responsible and just move on
from that moment.
(whoosh)
- Thank you so much for watching!
- We made this video
because Unequal asked us to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
us to profile next,
leave it in the comments below.
I will see what we can do.
- We would love to know
which one of his top 10
rules that you liked the most.
Please leave in the comments below,
we will join in discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
Dream to believe.
We'll see you soon.
- Bye!
- Got that Puerto Rican
band happening behind us.
(whoosh)